every day in the united states hundreds
of lives are saved by emts and
paramedics
and this week they are celebrated as
part of ems week glenn simpson
uh he is the director of special
operations for community ambulance joins
us to talk about
some of the activities going on to
celebrate ems week and community
ambulance in particular glenn
is celebrating a little more than 10
years in the valley now
yeah good afternoon everyone community
ambulance this is actually our going
into our 11th year
in the business here being proudly
serving not only the city of henderson
but all of
southern nevada and this this week it's
an opportunity
for us to take a moment and recognize
the the work that
our employees do throughout the year but
especially
this past year as we come out of this
pandemic what a year it has been and so
many adjustments have been made
by community ambulance and other
paramedics
adjusting to the covid situation what
are some of those changes and what do
you see moving forward
you know i i i would be remissed if i
didn't say just the
the amount of courage and dedication
that each of our employees every day
in the face of danger in the face of a
pandemic in the face of whatever it is
coming to work showing up every day
responding for that call
and not necessarily knowing what's on
the other side of that call and so our
crew has continued to do that
as call volume increases as our city
opens back up they continue to meet that
call they continue to meet
the expectations and we continue to
proudly serve this
city as a whole yeah i know community
ambulance over the years has always
sponsored a lot of blood drives in
conjunction with american red cross
you continue to do that and it's even
more important or has been more
important over this past year
yeah you're absolutely correct you know
with with the pandemic and a lot of
closures
it didn't mean that medical emergencies
still weren't taking place
the need for blood was there and there
was an even more need for blood because
of the lack of donations and
you know our team stood up and got got
everybody together partnered with the
american red cross and we hosted several
blood drives throughout the year
um you know right now we're in a mode of
every day we're putting more than
50 of our personnel out there throughout
the community to help vaccinate
at various pop-up clinics as well as mgm
resorts and
other properties within the strip
corridor and so we're really focused on
just getting the city back open and
doing it
as safely as we can i know a lot of
people
when uh the quarantine began had
reservations about
calling for an ambulance because of the
conditions that they believed existed in
hospitals
have call and so as a result calls went
down have you seen those numbers go back
up
yeah you're absolutely right or we saw a
significant drop in our call volume we
believe that was out of a lot of fear
of folks being afraid of going to the
hospital because of the environment
we are starting to see those call
volumes pick back up um you know it's
uh it happens to also this month happens
to be stroke awareness month and
it's just one of those emergencies that
we can't stress enough that you know
pick up the phone call 9-1-1
we're here to serve the community we
take a lot of precautions to
ensure that the back of the ambulance is
sanitized properly
and we work in conjunction with all of
our hospital partners to ensure that
you get the care that you need in the
safest cleanest possible way
we mentioned this is ems week and you
guys have uh
a series of activities going on for that
yeah you know there's it's
it's so hard to say thank you uh to the
employees and what they do and we
this community has stood behind us from
the events of one october
um to present day and they continue to
support us and so it's our small
small token of appreciation and so uh
this week you know everything from small
barbecues to
taco truck to this saturday we'll be
renting out part of lifeguard arena and
then taking everybody to the to the
baseball game next week at the uh
where the las vegas aviators take on
salt lake city so
anything we can do to give back to our
employees and just kind of
say a little bit of thank you well glenn
uh thanks for all that you and community
ambulance have done for the community
and to paramedics everywhere
for serving the community throughout
this whole pandemic and glad to see
things starting to get back to normal
appreciate you joining us today
thanks kendall it's absolutely our
pleasure thank you